[LAUGHTER]
ALL RIGHT, THE CARAVAN HIT THE
FAN, OR RATHER A PARADE OF
UNCHECKED IMMIGRANTS HIT A
WALL, AN ORANGE WALL.
A 71-YEAR-OLD CHEESEBURGER
EATING WALL THAT IS DONALD
TRUMP.
HIS BLOOD RESPONSE TO A PLAN
SYMBOLIC WAY OF IMMIGRANTS
FROM HONDURAS AND THE CARAVAN
BECAME A CARA VAN SOMEWHERE IN
MEXICO.
THEY CALLED HIS BLUFF AND HE
SAID ENOUGH, BUT WERE THEY
REALLY COMING ANYWAY?
WHO KNOWS.
WHAT A SLAMDUNK FOR DT.
THE GUY HAS BEEN ALL OVER
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
WELLIES PRESIDENT SEND A
THOUSAND PEOPLE TO THE
BORDER.
NOT HAPPENING.
HERE'S AN EXAMPLE OF THE NEW
SCHOOL BEING SCHOOLED BY THE
OLD SCHOOL.
THE OLD WORLD DUDE FACED OFF
AT THE MOVEMENT AND THE
MOVEMENT LIVED ON.
REMINDS ME OF A MOVIE.
>> IN A WORLD WHERE THE BORDER
IS LAWLESS AND THE BOUNDARY IS
LAWLESS, THEY SENT A CARAVAN
AND HE SENT AN ARMY.
IT'S A SMALL STEP FOR MAN.
>> SORRY, IT'S A BIG STEP.
WITH FEDERAL LAW, DEMOCRATS
KICK THE CAN DOWN THE ROAD OR
THE BALL DOWN THE FIELD.
EITHER WAY ONE MAN SAID NO
BRO, NOT MY COUNTRY.
[LAUGHTER]
, TRUMP AND RIC FLAIR AS THE
NATURE BOY.
EXECUTIVE ACTION 11 ORDER AT
THE BORDER.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THERE IS ANOTHER REASON WHY
THE CARAVAN FAILED IN SOCIETY
BIGGEST BEEF IS ALWAYS LINE
CUTTING WHICH IS PREDICATED ON
DIRE NEED.
THE MANY, MANY PEOPLE IN MY
STUDIO AUDIENCE WAITED IN
LINE.
[LAUGHTER]
IT SEEMS WE FORGOT WHY.
HERE IS A PRIMER EVEN KIDS
WILL UNDERSTAND.
>> LINE CUTTING.
WHY IS A BAD?
YOU SHOULD KNOW THEY ARE AS
AMERICAN AS THE REVOLUTIONARY
WAR.
INFANTRY FOUR NATIONS HAD TO
WRITE
WITE
WAIE
WAIT THEIR TURN BEFORE
SHOOTING EACH OTHER WITH
MUSKETS.
FOUR OUT OF FIVE SIGNS AGREE
THAT WITHOUT LINES WE WOULD'VE
NEVER WON OUR INDEPENDENCE.
YOU CAN SEE LINES FOR
EVERYWHERE.
ON GORDON RAMSAY FOR HEAD.
AT IPHONE RELEASES AND
FOOTBALL GAMES.
YOU WON'T SEE LINES THAT MARIN
FIVE CONCERTS.
WHEN LINES ARE LONG SOME LIKE
TO CUT THE WHOLE THING LEAVING
THOSE WHO FOLLOW THE RULES OUT
THE COLD.
DOESN'T SEEM FAIR UNLESS YEAR
IN A PLACE WHERE YOU CAN ASK
FOR SANCTUARY BUT THAT'S A
CONVERSATION FOR ANOTHER PLACE
AND TIME.
THAT'S WHY LINE CUTTING IS
BAD.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
EVERYONE ELSE WHO CAME HERE
THE RIGHT WAY WISHES EVERYONE
ELSE WOULD DO THE SAME THING
FOR THE LEFT MET ANOTHER
WALL.
CALL IT A COLLUSION
COLLISION.
>> AFTER A YEAR OF THOROUGH
INVESTIGATION AND GOING AFTER
ALL THE LOW HANGING FRUIT, IF
THEY COULDN'T HAVE SHIFTED HIM
FROM A SUBJECT TO A TARGET,
THERE'S NOTHING THERE.
NOW THE GOING AFTER WEEK
ISSUES, COLLUSION.
I CHALLENGE MULLER TO TELL ME
WHAT STATUTE IS VIOLATED BY
COLLUSION.
>> WAS THE NEWS THAT TRUMP IS
NOT A TARGET A PLUS FOR TRUMP
IN A SETBACK FOR HIS FOES AT
CNN?
WE STOP BY THE OFFICE FOR,
WE STOP BY THE OFFICE FOR.
SO, WHERE IS THE IMPEACHMENT
CARAVAN NOW?
HEADING INTO ANOTHER WALL.
NO SURPRISE, HAVE EVEN THOUGHT
THIS THING THROUGH?
SERIOUSLY, WHAT HAPPENS IF THE
IMPEACHMENT ENDS AND THEY GET
EXACTLY WHAT THEY WANT.
WHAT DO THEY END UP WITH?
[LAUGHTER]
THAT IS YOUR PLAN?
I LOVE THAT PLAN.
REPLACE A REPUBLICAN WITH A
GUY WHO SO RIGHT WAITING HE
MAKES GENGHIS KHAN LOOK LIKE
GRANDPA WALTON.
THEY NEVER HAVE A PLAN.
ALWAYS SEEKING TO REPLACING
THAT WORK, FREE MARKET, A
BORDER, PRESIDENT WITH CRAB.
COMMUNISM, SOCIALISM, IDENTITY
POLITICS.
TOFU.
NO WONDER EVERYTHING THEY
TOUCH AND SUFFERING.
IF HISTORY WAS OUR GUIDE WE
WOULD BUILD A WALL AROUND
THEM.
BUT LAST AND NEVER LEAST, THE
FORMER FIRST LADY COMPARED
DONALD TRUMP TO A BAD PARENT.
>> EIGHT YEARS THAT BARACK
OBAMA WAS PRESENT WAS SORT OF
LIKE HAVING A GOOD PARENT HOME
AND NOW PERHAPS WE HAVE THE
OTHER PARENT MAYBE IT FEELS
FUN FOR NOW BECAUSE WE CAN EAT
CANDY ALL DAY AND STAY UP LATE
AND NOT FOLLOW THE RULES.
>> THAT WASN'T A BAD METAPHOR
EXCEPT FOR THE LAST LINE.
IT FEELS FUN FOR NOW BECAUSE
WE CAN EAT CANDY ALL DAY.
WHAT'S THE CANDY?
IS IT MORE JOBS?
LES ISIS?
PROGRESS WITH NORTH KOREA, TAX
CUTS BECAUSE OF THAT THE CANDY
WHAT DOES THAT MAKE DONALD
TRUMP?
>> THE CANDY MAN ♪
♪ HE MAKES THE WORLD TASTE
GOOD.
♪ CANDY MAN.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
'S LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUEST HE'S LIKE JAMES BOND BUT
WITH BETTER HAIR.
FORMER CIA OFFICER BUCK
SEXTON.
LIKE FALLING THROUGH A PLATE
GLASS WINDOW, HE WILL LEAVE
YOU IN STITCHES.
SHE IS ONLY CHEERFUL WHEN SHE
HAS A BEER FOR.
[APPLAUSE]
AND, HE CAN LITERALLY MOVE
MOUNTAINS.
[APPLAUSE]
SO, BUCK, I HAVE TO HAND IT TO
DONALD TRUMP ON THIS.
THIS WAS A YEARLY POLITICAL
STUNT AND ACTIVIST GROUP TWO
RAISE AWARENESS ABOUT ASYLUM
SEEKERS AND SO FORTH.
HE REPURPOSED THE FOR HIS LAW
AND ORDER PERSPECTIVE ON IT
SEEMS LIKE IT WORKED.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> WE ALSO HAVE MORE DATA
ABOUT WHAT ENDS UP HAPPENING.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF 25
-YEAR-OLDS SHOWING UP AT THE
BORDER SAYING THEIR 17 AND
THAT'S JUST BEEN ESTABLISHED.
>> I'VE BEEN TRICKED BY THAT.
THEY TELL ME THEY'RE 25.
ALSO, WHEN I THINK PEOPLE
STARTED TO RECOGNIZE IS THAT
THEY ARE NOT ILLEGAL.
THIS IS A CARAVAN GOING
THROUGH THE MOUNTAINSIDES
LOOPHOLE WHERE THEY LITERALLY
SHOW UP TO BORDER PATROL AND
THEY SAY HERE WE ARE, CAN YOU
PUT US ON THE BUS AND SEND US
TO THE PLACE WHERE YOU GIVE
PEOPLE THE FREE PLACE TO SAY
IN THE FOOD AND TELL ME TOO
SHOP IN IMMIGRATION COURT AND
ABOUT FIVE YEARS AND WILL SEE
HOW THAT GOES.
>> JOE, I THINK THIS WAS POOR
PLANNING.
HERE YOU HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO
SO OLD WORLD AND THEY SAY
LET'S JUST SEND A THOUSAND
PEOPLE TO THE BORDER.
HE WON'T DO ANYTHING.
>> A CARAVAN IS A TERRIBLE WAY
TO SNEAK INTO A COUNTRY UNLESS
IT'S A DODGE CARAVAN.
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT, THEY'RE
UPSET ABOUT THE PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION IN HONDURAS.
I DON'T THINK THAT THAT ARE
GOING TO LIKE THE PRESIDENT
HERE BECAUSE TRUMP PROBABLY
WOULD'VE DONE WELLIN THAT
ELECTION.
>> CAT, I KIND OF THINK, WHAT
BUMS ME OUT ABOUT THE CARAVAN,
IT'S ACTUALLY AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE, PEOPLE TRYING TO GET
OUT OF BAD COUNTRIES, BUT HOW
CAN JUST BEING A CITIZEN OF A
COUNTRY MAKE YOU AN ASYLUM
SEEKER.
THERE HAS TO BE WAR AND HOWL
AND PETULANCE.
>> I WOULD AGREE WITH THAT.
>> THANK YOU GUESS THAT WASN'T
MUCH OF A QUESTION.
>> I THINK THE ONE ISSUE I HAD
IS THAT TRUMP SAID THIS
REPRESENTED A MASSIVE INFLUX
OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS WHEN
REALLY BORDER PATROL AGENT
SAID THIS IS PRETTY TYPICAL OF
WHAT THEY SEE EVERYDAY.